where do forces come from all forces
arise from the interaction of two
objects with each other in this example
we have two objects one and two
interacting with each other in this case
because there are surfaces are in
contact with each other one sitting on
top of the other and the interaction
between the two objects gives rise to a
pair of forces I have one force that's
acting from object two down on object
one and the other force that's acting
from object one back up onto object two
and these forces following Newton's
third law are equal in magnitude and
opposite in direction what if we now
push these blocks horizontally in
opposite directions at their interface
there is a frictional interaction this
interaction gives rise to a pair of
frictional forces that are parallel to
the interface the friction force on the
top block from the bottom block is
opposite and direction but equal in
magnitude to the friction from the
bottom block due to the top block let's
look at some of the common
misconceptions about forces first of all
motion is not a force if I have a block
that's moving at a constant velocity
along a frictionless plane then there is
no horizontal force that's acting on
this block because there is no
interaction that would give rise to a
horizontal force the fact that it has a
velocity does not necessarily mean that
there is a force acting on it another
common mistake is to think that forces
transfer through objects for example if
I'm pushing a book against a wall it
might seem like the force from my hand
is being transferred to the wall but
what is really happening is that there
are two independent interactions the
interaction of my hand with the book and
the interaction of the book with the
wall and these are separate interactions
the forces might happen to have the same
magnitude in some cases but it's not
because the force from my hand is being
transferred forces arise between pairs
of objects and those horses can only act
on those two objects
let's look more closely at Newton's
third law so Newton's third law says
that when there are two objects that are
interacting there will be two forces
that arise from that interaction and
these two forces are always equal in
magnitude and opposite in direction
these two forces this Newton's third law
pair of forces never act on the same
object but instead one force acts on the
first object and one on the second
because these forces arise out of the
same interaction they have to be the
same type of force so they could be
gravitational forces frictional forces
normal forces etc let's look at an
example of a book sitting on a table
it's being pulled down by the
gravitational force and it's being held
up by the normal force are these two
forces a news third law pair the book is
not accelerating so these forces are
equal in magnitude and opposite in
direction but they cannot be a Newton's
third law pair for two different reasons
first of all they both act on the same
object the book and second of all they
arise from different interactions the
normal force on the book is part of a
Newton's third law pair that comes from
the interaction between the book and the
table
what's the Newton's third law pair of
the gravitational force on the book well
because the gravitational forces arises
from the interaction between the book
and the earth the other force in the
Newton's third law pair is actually the
force that the book exerts on the earth
you might not think about the book
acting on the earth but the force is
actually equal and opposite to the
Earth's force on the book it's just that
the earth is so much more massive the
force has no detectable influence on the
Earth's behavior behavior at all